joining us now as we continue our
special investigation and reacting to
today's breaking news Ohio Congressman
Jim Jordan Florida congressman Ron de
Santos and Judicial Watch president tom
Fitton Congressman Jim Jordan let me
start with you sir this is an amazing
thing that rod Rosenstein who appointed
robert muller
who is the same guy that extended the
FISA warrant with the phony dossier
which was the bulk of information he's
he did not want Devon newness to get any
of this material and that only because
of digging by you and Congressman
meadows and your staffs were we able to
find the latest stripe page messages
which show all of this you know
collusion if you will to use a term or
at least a relationship with this judge
that recused himself after he accepted
general Flynn right plea right exactly
right so on three key points here you
know you said it well the judge refuses
himself in the Flynn case that same
judge the text messages make very clear
had a friendship and relationship with
Peter struck the guy who was you know
deputy head of counterintelligence at
the FBI and the eff use me the Justice
Department made it difficult for us to
get that information
in fact the copies that we got the
documents that we got were redacted we
had to send staff mr. meadows staff went
in there and found the information which
shows the relationship so he recused
himself as you said after the case not
before he had a relationship that judge
had a relationship with Peter struck and
the Justice Department didn't want us to
find it out the key question is why well
let's say let's go through that key
question Rhonda Santas that is a key
question why why why would you judge
doesn't take on a case then recuse
himself and then we find the judge is
best friends with the guy at the heart
of everything Peter struck yes Shawn and
I mean just remember this was such an
odd case from the beginning with Flynn
they rushed in to interrogate him in the
White House January of 2017
obviously he ends up pleading guilty but
he probably didn't know all that was
going on with Peter struck
and so this thing just is not does not
sit well with me and I also have an
issue as Jimmy said with the Department
of Justice
they fought us tooth and nail not on
everything pretty much
including this right here why were they
heavily redacted this portion that was
something that we were entitled to see
in conducting oversights they tried to
hide it from the American people yeah
and and tom Fitton you have struggled
and your organization has struggled and
this gets up why are they trying to hide
remember Devon Nunez waited till the
final five minutes before the subpoena
of this information from the DOJ that
should have been handed over much
earlier and now congressman Jordon
congressman meadows congressman de
santis they have to send there's entire
staffs over they they can't even take a
picture of anything it's like don't they
have oversight isn't that part of checks
and balances oversight committees are to
check and balance to make sure that
things don't go wrong
well they resist oversight not only from
Congress the Department of Justice and
FBI do but also from the courts I mean
we're in federal court asking for these
types of text messages we're asking why
haven't we gotten them yet we know you
have them wife and you turn them over on
the cave and struck in Page we've asked
for them months ago and we're getting
the proverbial hand to the face there's
this culture of arrogance at the FBI and
Justice Department that impedes
virtually any oversight either by
judicial watch through the courts or
Congress through its constitutional
powers and it's real concerning that
this isn't happening during the Obama
administration but by appointees of
President Trump you know Jeff Sessions
has got a step up and take back control
of the Justice Department rod Rosenstein
has a personal interest it seems to me
in keeping this information away and
director ray is completely out to lunch
on these issues where he's more
concerned about the institution of the
FBI and protecting its reputation than a
cleaning house in terms of the
corruption issues
Minoo and now we've got this issue now
about the court you know we've been
doing I know a little bit about the
judicial ethics process
I can tell you it's unusual for a court
to recuse themselves from a case like
this without an explanation it's unusual
and these new taxes he raised questions
about what was going on and why the
court recused himself without telling
the public what was the reason for doing
so in such a high-profile case Jim she
went to weigh in yeah Shawn it's unusual
for the judge to recuse himself at any
time it's really unusual for him to
recuse himself after the case has been
designed you make the better you make a
judge can terraces relationship with
Peter struck and all of us well and also
Peter struction relationship with
Michael Flynn he was there at the
interview of Michael Flynn was
supposedly Flynn said something Falls to
the FBI so that I don't know how this
all fits together that's why all we're
saying is these three key facts happened
there was a recusal there was a
relationship between the judge and Peter
struck a central figure in this whole
affair and the Department of Justice was
making it very difficult for Congress to
as as both Tom and Ron have pointed out
to do our constitutional oversight those
three facts are indisputable so let's
ask why that was the case why can't we
get the information and why in fact did
this judge recuse himself let's go let's
go back to the this new reveal and it
says congressman DeSantis in a text
message which struck a page - struck
Rudy meeting judge Ken Terrace is on the
FISA Court did you know that just
appointed two months ago and they
discuss some of the things that of
course Peter struck comes back I did we
talked about it before and after I need
to get together with him this is these
two hate Donald Trump and then they're
best friends with a judge on the FISA
Court now there were four separate FISA
Court judges that were all lied to
because they never informed the the
judges and the applications that Hillary
had bought and paid for unverified
uncorroborated what turned out to be
many Russian lies to influence the
election congressman well I'll tell you
you know Peter struck has done so much
damage to the reputation of the FBI with
his arrogance I mean him and Lisa Paige
are sitting there saying well let's me
you facture a social setting or a dinner
party so I can talk with them and he
won't have to recuse himself type of
deal but you're right we need to get all
the documents about all the other FISA
applications
I know Contreras was probably one of the
judges but we don't know which one the
Justice Department will not give us the
transcripts they won't give us the
documents and you have to ask yourself
why would they not want to do this if
this was all on the up-and-up wouldn't
you want to clear the air so that the
American people can move on but yet they
fight us tooth and nail on every issue
and what other information are you
looking for tom Fitton
you know sure we want the FISA
applications to you know what was
interesting is that we we understood the
FISA Court was misled these new text
messages now raise questions about
whether the FISA Court process was
corrupted internally and I don't know if
any judge did anything wrong but
certainly there's enough for the court
to begin an internal investigation of
how the judges communicated with the FBI
where all the communications appropriate
and disclosed in a way that the public
can be shirred assured that there was
the fair administration of justice in
the operations of the FISA Court I tell
you this corruption at the Obama Justice
Department and FBI which continues in
some way today not only ruined the
Justice Department and FBI it's now
splashed on to the courts what a
disaster
so it only congressman Jordan yeah
because they go ahead you got to send
your staff over every day yeah yeah
that's the only way we can get the
information that has to happen now every
day I want to be I want to be real clear
we do not know if Judge if this judge in
any way signed off on either for FISA
warrants what we do know is this this
series of facts raises concerns and and
raises the obvious question of why it
happened one of the figure skaters in
the country that has so much power is
bragging about his relationship and that
in fact the judge knows all about what
he does yep sure is yeah all right let's
take you all I appreciate it you